من رام الله الخبير والمحلل العسكري واصف
عريقات سيد واصف عريقات في متابعتك ل
الاعداد التي يعلن عنها جيش الاحتلال من
القتلى في صفوف ضباطه وجنوده والمصابين
ايضا يوميا ما هي المعلومات او ما هي
المؤشرات التي يمكن التوقف عندها
والمتغيرات بالنظر الى ما هو معلن وبالنظر
الى ما تتحدث عنه
الصحف يعني واضح انه القياده العسكريه
والسياسيه الاسرائيليه تسابق الزمن هي
تريد ان تحقق بعض الانجازات على الارض
لذلك تدفع بمزيد من القوات
اي تحاول ان تحقق هذه الانجازات من خلال
هذا الدفع للقوات ولكن انا بتقديري
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تنتظرهم وخاصه ان هذه
المرحله التي تجنبها الجيش الاسرائيلي
كثيرا يعني حينما حينما بدا المرحلتين
الاولى والثانيه والثالثه حتى كان يعتمد
على الجندي الاسرائيلي مختبئا بدبابته
مستعرضا عس بعس بشكل عسكري ومسلح بمدفع
وطيران يسانده في كل لحظه الان اراد ان
يحقق بعض الانجازات بتمدد داخل بعض
الاحياء ليحقق بعض الانجازات هنا
يعني يجرد الجندي والضابط الاسرائيلي من
سلاح الاسناد سواء كان من الطائرات او من
المدفعيه ويضطر للمواجهه المباشره مع مع
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وهذه فرصه
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين ان يعني يقنص
ويشتبك مع هؤلاء الجنود والضباط ويوقعوا
هذا العدد الكبير من الخسائر في صفوفهم
لذلك انا بتقديري الجيش
الاسرائيلي بما انه يتحدث الان عن انه
سينتقل الى المرحله الثالثه وهي تقليص
العمليات البريه وتقليص الهجمات الصاروخيه
لذلك هو يتعجل الامور ويحاول تحقيق هذه
بعض الانجازات حتى يذهب الى هدنه او وقف
لاطلاق النار كيف يبدو اثر سيد واصف اثر
الاعلان عن مقتل الضباط والجنوب برتب
عاليه من الالويه النخبوي المفترض بانها
نخبويا في الجيش الاسرائيلي مثل جفعاتي
وجولان والمظليين
مثلا يعني بالتاكيد هذه تؤثر على الروح
المعنويه عند الاسرائيليين بشكل عام وعند
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني حتى الجنود والضباط
الذين يقتل منهم هذا الكم من الاعداد انا
بتقديري تتدنى روحهم المعنويه وروحهم
القتاليه وخاصه ان انهم
يعني ذاهبون الى قطاع غزه ب ومسكون بعقيده
هني بعل يعني انه ذاهب الى قطاع غزه اما
قتيلا او اسيرا وحينما يسمع عن هذا الكم
من من الخسائر انا بتقديري تضعف معنوياته
وروح القتاليه ويصبح عاجزا عن القيام
بمهامه العسكريه ويصبح فريسه للمقاومين
الفلسطينيين ا طيب بالتالي يعني كل ذلك
كيف يضغط على ارض المعركه وعلى الخيارات
الاسرائيليه بالذهاب الى هدنه انسانيه من
اجل تبادل الاسرى كما تتحدث اسرائيل بانها
يعني تريد ان تضغط على حماس من اجل تحسين
شروط التفاوض لصالحها وتنزيل السقوف
لحماس
ولكن واضح انه الضغط ياتي على اسرائيل
وليس على المقاومه الفلسطينيه لانه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه موجوده على ارضها
وتقاتل وصامد حتى الان والروح المعنويه
عند المقاتلين الفلسطينيين في اعلى مستوى
بعكس الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي لم يحقق اولا
اهدافه بعد 75 يوم هناك 100 ال جندي
اسرائيلي جاؤوا ليحققوا هدفين الهدف الاول
القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولم
ينجزوا اي شيء من هذا بدليل لان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قويه وقادره وتتصدى
لهم والهدف الثاني تحرير الاسرى والرهائن
بالقوه العسكريه وهذا ايضا لم يحدث حاولوا
مره واحده تحرير اسير بالقوه العسكريه قتل
الاسير وقتلت الوحده الخاصه التي جاءت
تحرره ولولا تدخل الطيران الاسرائيلي لوقع
لوقعت الوحده الخاصه في يد الفلسطينيين
كاسرى فلذلك يعني لا لا يوجد الان
امام الجيش الاسرائيلي اي ورقه
قويه حتى يقول انه ذاهب الى الهدنه بناء
على الضغط العسكري الضغط العسكري ربما
يعني اضر بالاسرائيليين اكثر مما اضر
بالفلسطينيين وها هي نتائج على الارض
واضحه الفلسطيني بالصوت والصوره يظهر
مقاطع كيف يحقق الانجازات على الارض حين
في حين ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبث يعني
افلام تمثيليه لا لا اساس لها على ارض
الواقع وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل على ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ضعيف وهزيل وغير قادر
على تنفيذ المهام التي اوكلت اليه شكرا
جزيلا لك من رام الله الخبير والمحلل
العسكري واصف عريقات اهلا